yeah it's quick tip smile during the
interview I've been learning a lot about
different personality types in my site
course in your kind of textbook
borderline all brains no empathy you
know Luke we are so very proud of all
the hard work you're doing and I look
forward to hearing your insights when
you finish chapter 2 but for now maybe
you could just put that book away no
surprise you'd say that
controlling obsessive plastic comment on
personality type Oh grow up Haley
sadly she can't such as the plight of
the Peter Pan personality you're
something Haley refuses to grow up I
don't believe that which brings us to
another type the dreamer head in the
clouds tends to be naive gullible
however you're smart now yes indeed we
have watched him grow up on Modern
Family Season ten is underway here to
talk through what's next for him and the
show Nolan Gould is joining us in studio
thank you so much for being here thanks
for having me alright I let your
character is so like just the dryness
that funniness yeah
how much fun are you having playing him
at ten seasons Oh Oh totally I mean I
absolutely loved it I loved like that
I'd get to be that dry because I am
naturally that dries like in a way I'm
playing myself but I get to have
somebody else write my words for me oh I
wish I wish someone would like write my
words for me like embarrassing do you
ever find yourself accidentally saying
lines from the show just in conversation
you're like oh I think that oh yeah
totally I are I just steal jokes from
the show we've got the like the best
career of writers and the entire
Hollywood like might as well you know
yeah this passion awesome and are you
guys like are other people having what
you're having where you're becoming
you're the carrot the line between
character and person gets harder
blurrier that that line faded so long
ago we have morphed into the same person
I used to say it was super different
from Luke and that's just not the case
and I don't know it's because of because
of playing him for so long or it was
just like puberty but like my my brain
were like away announces me and Luke are
like what about the rest of the cast you
see them have their characters a little
bit no actually I'd say most
pretty different from their characters I
definitely looked at and we rub off on
each other so like a lot of times like
loop will pick up things so like I do
first I'm like would they even read an
episode where Luke learns how to play a
banjo there's actually like a banjo
prodigy I know you playing the banjo ah
yes I'm not a banjo prodigy I'm like I
was like five years of playing I can
like you can and I want to ask you the
show's had some major milestones lately
a death now we just found out Haley is
pregnant yes what can you tell us about
well if you're not caught up get caught
up what can you tease about how that
pregnancy is gonna affect everything and
will we see any other major milestones
like that coming up um definitely yeah I
think the pregnancy is gonna shake up a
lot on our show um
he's one of those characters that I mean
especially like her storylines she's
always kind of been trying to like
choose her life and like choose her love
life and I think there's like the first
time we're like she's not in control
whatsoever and this is something that's
kind of been given to her and that's
we're gonna we're gonna see her dealing
with that and like the entire family
obviously um it's gonna make interesting
storylines for Phil and Claire well this
is the big question is is this the wrap
down of Modern Family are you guys
getting close to the end what do you
think yes I think but also no I don't
think so I'm gonna be I know would be
real vague here officially this is our
last season obviously a lot can change
and I know that as a cast we all I mean
we love it we have the best job ever
I can't believe that I get to go in
every day and work with this amazing
cast and crew so obviously there's
always a chance always a chance well and
I know you're doing you know you're not
doing this other movie that's coming out
you're doing other acting if the show
wraps down do you see yourself
continuing and acting or is there
anything else you'd want to pursue um
totally I mean it's so hard to make
plans for your life as an actor I'm
basically I'm basically unemployed all
the time even though I've been working
at any restraint so I would love to keep
acting yeah I just I finished a movie
called
yes and it's a super super dark
independent movie which is gonna be
exciting
people to see me play something
completely different from Luke really
looking forward to that and I mean but
at the same time there is so much that
interest me in the world I just recently
got into writing so I I wrote a pilot
with my writing partner
well here's the thing Nolan I just
learned this about you and I almost feel
like we've got to like get to know Nolan
we know you from the show but you know
you're doing this darker role with this
movie you're writing and I found it you
have an IQ of 150 I do yes you are in
Mensa I am yeah this is what is it like
to have an IQ of 150 you've finished
high school at 13 even before your
co-star Sarah Hyland did and she's older
than you what is it like to have an IQ
of 150 like do you or are you just like
I gotta find a conversation or someone
who can challenge me it's I mean first
it's always interesting when people ask
me about being a quote/unquote genius
it's always really hard to like respond
to people I heard your genius and like
then do you feel pressured to make
yourself sound smart I was like Oh
indubitably yeah let me also ask you
though because other celebrities are in
Mensa and and one Natalie Portman Matt
Damon Ashton Kutcher Kanye West has also
said he is in Mensa now he is in Mensa
or he said he's in then I think he said
he he is or he could be here that he's
Mensa qualified like what is it - how do
you actually get in Mensa and when
you're in there do you talk to the other
members like what is the organisation
like that yeah yeah yeah we mainly just
play Dungeons and Dragons and talk about
nuclear fusion in our microwave question
is have you met Kanye through months I
haven't met Connie I've never heard
about Khan they're showing up to a
meeting so yeah I don't even think he's
paying his dude come on Kanye like if
you're gonna be part of the men's a
community you got to show up are there
Mensa meetings there are other
celebrities huh I've not met other
celebrities Thurmond's uh I actually
yeah I don't know I've never yeah
personally met I think Julie should be
that's all I'm going to say okay like
Julie is a one of the smartest people
I've ever met I'm plays my mom in the
show she needs to be in it all right
we're gonna get Julie Meza and speaking
some important work you're doing I know
you're involved with this charity you're
actually going to do some work
weekend there right yes best buddies
best bet yeah so best buddy is it's a
really great organization it helps kids
who are learning challenged help find
jobs in the real world and kind of
assimilate more into society whether
that's their jobs or friendships
mentoring with with the kids in school
it's really great way to yeah help out
kids with who are learning challenged
yeah
it's what's really great you know Nolan
I have loved getting to know known a
little bit more guys check out his new
movie yes where can people watch it oh
well I mean we just finished it so it's
yeah it's probably gonna be on the indie
film circuit awesome thank you so much
for being here of course watch modern
family and we will see where the show
takes us and where your career takes you
know and modern family is Wednesday
nights on ABC
thank you so much thanks for having me
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]